chinese tennis star punk schwai has
resurfaced after nearly three weeks of
silence and global concern that she had
been detained in china punk spoke with
the international olympic committee
president in a video call her appearance
comes weeks after she accused one of the
communist party's top leaders in sexual
assault ramion asensio is following the
latest developments from hong kong
raymie good morning
nate good morning that's right this is
very very significant because it's
punctualized first
real-time direct contact with an outside
organization ever since she disappeared
from public view nearly three weeks ago
she met thomas bach the president of the
international olympic committee and she
assured him quote that she is safe and
well
the ioc released this single still from
that video chat of a smiling pong and a
statement that said she was at home in
beijing and wanted to have her privacy
respected
that came after the release of this
seemingly scripted and stage managed
video of pong and her tennis coach with
forced references to the date of
november 21st released on twitter by the
editor of the global times communist
tabloid
this video of her waving to spectators
at the china open sunday morning and
these weekend photos of pong playing
with a cat all calling into more
question whether she was acting under
duress
on november 2nd the 35 year old
wimbledon and french open doubles champ
and three-time olympian had publicly
accused former vice premier john gauli a
close ally of chinese president xi
jinping of sexual coercion about three
years ago pong's four paragraph note on
chinese social media was quickly deleted
all references to her name were censored
through sunday an email allegedly from
pung then retracted everything the
author wrote the allegation of sexual
assault is not true i'm not missing nor
am i unsafe following pong's video chat
with the ioc the chair of the athletes
commission wrote i was relieved to see
that punxhua was doing fine she appeared
to be relaxed i offered her our support
china risk analyst isaac stonefish is
unconvinced it's certainly quite
suspicious that the
international olympic committee an
organization known for its close ties
with beijing
was the western conduit for
alleged video chat with pong
the winter olympics in beijing are set
to start in just a few months on
february 4th the women's tennis
association had threatened to pull all
of its games out of china at the very
least the world now has the answer to
where is pangshwai
now it's a question of whether beijing
will actually launch a probe into punk's
accusations of sexual assault by a top
communist party official but with pong
smiling and calling for privacy it at
least feels at least that an
investigation is further off than before
tony
raymie innocencio for us in hong kong
raymie thank you very much